look up
savage kiss in the dictionary and you'll
find little saint west
blowing raspberries on his famous mama
kim kardashian's cheeks
[Music]
on thursday the 40 year old reality star
hit up her insta story to share
that sweet clip of her four-year-old son
laughing as he laid one
seriously wet af kiss on her face
[Laughter]
you know what you know what
i like you you know
tim captioned the clip asking what we're
all thinking
has anyone heard of a savage kiss no kim
confirming no we have not i mean we've
heard of savage love
[Music]
and savage by fenty because rihanna
was a duh but savage kiss
that's a new one i like you you know
looks like kim is still getting a whole
lot of kiddo time under quarantine amid
the coronavirus pandemic
having kids is just there's no way to
describe it but it's a lot
before she shared that savage kiss the
mama 4 posted a clip of a sweet gift she
received from her sister chloe
but the kids were right there all up in
her business
wait each package comes with this
machine
and all of these recipes can you stop
leave me alone for one second to film
this
yeah and keeping up with the kardashians
gave us an inside look at what
quarantine life has been like in the
kardashian west household
[Music]
let's just say it's a 20 20 mood
my kids are driving me so up the wall
i literally don't know what to do
today they all were crying and
everyone's antagonizing each other and
shy's like mommy i want you and then
north is like mom i want you
and then i want you no i want you they
want to be up my [ __ ]
and she wasn't kidding her kids have
been on her like
white on rice okay so i walk into my
bathroom
oh my god there's like an arrangement
everywhere
oh my god why that's how i feel
because it's bad back in october the kkw
beauty founder received some epic
flowers for her 40th birthday
and her seven-year-old daughter north
was right by her side to throw down some
shady sarcasm as she filmed the florals
for the gram
christy oh my god chrissy you guys
firstly tegan can you like what is this
that is actually flowers to know and
back in april north straight up crashed
kim's stay-at-home psa
it's really important to also do mental
health checks on your friends and your
loved ones your busy of your
kids not your friends
facts oh and who could forget when kim
hid in the bathroom so she could film a
makeup tutorial
sans kids i'm hiding in the guest room
because my kids
will not leave me alone hey that's me
yeah that didn't work
north can i please just do my little
tutorial i i
it's all i want to do is one little fun
thing for myself